you
were great in this and the film is
fantastic i i mean
it really punched me in the face
emotionally
cool um so before i get into a lot of
specific questions i mentioned to a few
people i was going to be talking to you
and someone sent me a question
um i believe it says his name is a nick
stoller
um oh my god he said he wanted to know
if it was harder doing drama or acting
against a turkey puppet
voiced by brian possum
oh man well
you know i think it's got to be the
turkey puppet um
it was really hard you know the hardest
thing about comedy is not laughing
that is that for me has always been like
the joy
and pain of being surrounded by
brilliant brilliant people like
brian jonah hill seth like
uh that's that's the biggest challenge
is not laughing with those guys
uh i really enjoyed dispatches
and i really thanks and i really enjoy
your work
as an actor and over the last few years
you've been so selective
so this is a two-parter one what do i
need to do to get you to act more
and two um what was it about this
project that said i i need to be in this
yeah um well i think i'm gonna be doing
a lot more acting this year
um i was writing that show for about two
or three years dispatches from elsewhere
i did all the jobs on it um which i had
never done before
it was hard um
it was the first time in maybe like 20
years i felt like oh maybe i won't be
able to do it
which was a really it was just a really
exciting feeling
um what made me choose this role was
i uh i had an amazing experience
so i loved doing comedy i loved doing
comedy
i then had an amazing experience making
a movie called end of the tour where i
swung really hard towards drama
and then over the past few years with
dispatches too
i felt like oh there is now now let's
find
this middle ground where you get to do a
mix of all
all the things that you enjoy doing
drama and comedy
and this movie came along and felt like
it was a really
great both the character and the story
are this amazing fusion of the two
intentionally by their nature it's like
this
story of real tragedy and heartbreak um
as nicole t played by dakota johnson
slowly dies from cancer which happened
in real life
but the way it is framed is a story of
friendship
and laughter and love among these people
and that seemed like exactly what i
wanted to
do and should be doing one of the things
i think that
while obviously there's some very
serious stuff
in this movie and it's portrayed very
honestly
i think one of the surprises for me was
how much levity was in the movie
there's a great bit of you doing stand
stand-up in front of dakota
um can you sort of talk about for people
that might be like i don't know if i
want to
watch a downer movie there's a lot of
levity in this
yeah i mean i i think it's actually more
of an uplifting movie
than a downer uh you know it hits you
hard at the end
they get you it's like a magic trick um
how it sneaks up on you but i think it i
think part of the way that magic trick
is accomplished
is that most of the movie
is about a celebration of life
so that then when the death comes it's
especially sad
um but i would say i haven't thought of
it until now i would say that that's
actually probably what the movie is
about
it's it's a celebration of life and
friendship
against the hardest circumstances uh
something that is uh
interesting about this is that you guys
filmed in the real
in fairbanks i believe it's called yeah
yeah i'm sorry
uh and um obviously there are the people
that this
what the people that this story happened
to are standing there
watching you work um and so i'm very
curious as an actor what is that like
and
did you find yourself really like just
feeling a little bit more pressure
because the family might be there
watching you
um i did not feel more pressure
uh people weren't just watching some of
them were in it
there are these scenes of great
celebration as nicole is kind of ticking
off her bucket list
and the community is starting to
rally around her there's a scene where
she
one of her last wishes is she wants to
dance in this fountain
and in the center of town and the real
town came down
and we all got in that fountain and
what i felt like was that
the movie was a celebration of the life
of someone that these people all knew
um so i actually didn't feel pressure i
felt
quite honored does that make sense a
hundred percent
um one of the things about gabriela is
she has made documentaries and i think
what
what she brought to the table was this
she did a great job with where she
placed the camera and the feeling
and sort of being a fly on the wall can
you sort of talk about
the way she captures the film yes
it's really cool because what she is
most interested in
which is also what i'm most interested
in is
capturing authenticity between
action and cut and there are lots of
different amazing
styles of filmmaking and some of it is a
very
like more like a painting you know um
and this was not that this was closer
to the documentary end of the spectrum
in terms of acting
and so a lot of the scenes with the
girls are just
um hey jason i need you to make these
girls laugh
in this scene um some of the scenes with
casey are just like hey
you too i need you to get along in this
scene
talk about whatever you want to talk
about and that's really cool
and challenging you know um
yeah it was it was a really really great
experience
um i am curious you mentioned that
you're going to be doing more acting
do you know what you're going to
actually do this year do you have
specific projects
lined up i do yeah i just finished
something
uh called the sky is everywhere which i
was really lucky to film
over um over quarantine and i got to
i got to break up the year and go shoot
up in the redwoods
of california which was um
i'm really lucky uh and then yeah i have
a few things this year
starting to line up that i'll uh i'm
gonna have my first
really busy year than i've had in a
decade maybe
i look forward to this and uh listen i
really mean it uh i'm glad you're gonna
be acting more
congrats on this movie it's so well done
and i'll tell nick stoller you said hey
okay thank you it's great to see you